[Música]
eles já estão sozinhos da minha filha
laura ela começando ela fez um ano no
mês passado e começou a dar os primeiros
passinhos
é muito emocionante acho que
principalmente porque eu vejo como uma
primeira grande conquista né marco na
nossa história seus primeiros passos mas
vocês já pararam para pensar que ao
longo do tempo a gente vai perdendo a
liberdade e os primeiros passinhos se
apresentam
eu acho que tem muito a ver com o lugar
em que a gente mora eu acredito nisso
que o lugar que a gente mora vai dizer
muito sobre os nossos hábitos nosso
estilo de vida
na verdade tem muitos pesquisadores que
já falam que o nosso código postal
querendo dizer as características do
lugar em que a gente vive
vão dizer tanto ou mais sobre a nossa
saúde do que o nosso código genético
já pensaram nisso essa que só eu
178 anos corte de cabelo denuncia final
da década de 80 como e sim de 90 eu
olhando para trás agora vejo que eu
caminhei muito pouco na cidade que eu
morei é em um condomínio fechado
muitos acham que é um privilégio acho
que é mesmo o nome da segurança e pude
ver nesse bairro tinha 18 casas mas a
verdade é que o pouco sair daí eu pouco
vi a cidade que deixei pra fora desses
muros
eu não podia e até o pegasse bicicleta e
para a escola ou para o parto brincar
com alguém para a banca de jornal e
adorava ir à banca de jornal
sempre depende de uma carona lembro que
me incomodava muito da adolescência
quando a gente tem aquela urgência assim
de ser livre e independente
dependendo da carona dos pais para ir
para as festinhas para o cinema não
combinava né
mas
eu tiver sorte de poder ter visto e
vivido em outros lugares que me fizeram
repensar a importância do caminhar na
minha vida
no meu dia a dia mas também
profissionalmente eu sou arquiteta
urbanista eu acordo todos os dias para
trabalhar por cidades mais caminhar
weiss
eu vou contar para vocês aqui hoje um
pouquinho
esses motivos que fui encontrando ao
longo dessa minha trajetória para lutar
por cidades feitas pelas pessoas nas
cidades que são mais conectadas
acessíveis seguras confortáveis e porque
não também é atraente
eu acho que tudo começou quando fui para
o barcelona
eu fui como estudante de intercâmbio
pela faculdade de arquitetura e
urbanismo da usp chegando lá e conheci
uma pessoa muito especial
ele está aqui da platéia é falar aí ele
lembra um pouco tímido mas foi ele quem
mim me fez aprender a andar nessa
verdade porque todo dia depois que saí
do trabalho a gente saía para caminhar e
ele me mostrava que os cantinhos
escondidos a barcelona alternativa
daquela barcelona muito turística né
ele me mostrava os cantinhos que gostava
mais e percebi que caminhando às vezes
era a única maneira de descobrir os
lugares
eu percebi que caminhando é uma ótima
maneira de conhecer não só barcelona mas
tantas outras cidades por onde passei
porque minha tem início a gente está
numa velocidade que permite parar olhar
cumprimentar alguém lá do outro lado da
rua
tudo bom e aí tomar um café da preparar
e tomar um café de uma vitrine
se você descobrir uma para assim ali
sempre descansa um pouquinho no banco da
praça caminhar de permitir se você tem
que procurar uma vaga pra fazer aquilo
que você acabou de encontrar ali
descobri outra coisa também
caminha se conecta com a cidade eu fiz
uma matéria chamada caminhar barcelona
na universidade politécnica e no final
desta matéria a gente imprimiu o mapa
enorme da cidade
colocamos lá do lado do do edifício do
colégio de arquitetos de barcelona bem
no centro da cidade e que chamou muita
atenção foi que as pessoas consigam se
localizar na afirmar que a gente pedia
apenas desenhar seus trajetos que elas
faziam no dia a dia eu percebi que
pessoas de vários tipos de várias
cidades eram capazes de se localizar o
animal e desenhar esse percurso
pensei poxa está todo mundo hoje aqui a
pé usando o espaço público acho que
essas coisas estão ligadas
eu acho que quando a gente caminha a
gente consegue de fato se conectar com o
lugar e com as pessoas e construir esse
sentimento de pertencimento mesmo a
gente consegue se engajar com aquele
lugar a gente consegue construir um mapa
mental da cidade nossa cabeça quando
sair de barcelona percebi que eu
conhecia mais barcelona do que campinas
que foi a cidade onde eu nasci e cresci
esse tema me apaixonou e eu fui
trabalhar com um desenho urbano naquela
área da arquitetura e urbanismo de
permitir se aproximar um pouco mais
dessa temática então por isso fui fazer
um mestrado em nova york em desenho
urbano terminando o curso trabalha na
prefeitura de lá é na secretaria de
planejamento urbano e lá me aproximei
esse conceito é que o design foi
consagrado através desse manual lançado
em 2010 e eu percebia que as pessoas
estão tentando trabalhar com um tratado
um problema de saúde público que está
ilustrado é a nível nacional percebeu se
que havia um gasto muito grande com
doenças crônicas que as doenças crônicas
mata muita gente nos estados unidos e
depois eu descobri que em vários outros
países também são doenças como diabetes
doenças cardiovasculares alguns cânceres
o que elas têm em comum é o fato de que
o sedentarismo ea obesidade são gatilhos
para essas doenças
é esses dois essas duas coisas estão
ligadas ao nosso estilo de vida algumas
vezes cinco alguns fatores genéticos mas
principalmente o nosso estilo de vida
então o entendimento dessa galera lá do
ecodesign era talvez existe um desenho
de cidade e pode ajudar a gente a ter
uma alimentação mais saudável e praticar
atividade física no dia a dia
entre as várias diretrizes que o manual
coloca como melhorar o acesso a parques
e áreas criativas para todo mundo
investir na infraestrutura de bicicleta
fala se muito sobre caminhar porque o
caminho uma forma muito fácil né de
quase todos nós integramos essa
atividade física no dia a dia no nosso
ir ele e aí veio o estalo disse poxa né
falar das cidades mais caminhar weiss é
falar de saúde também fala de saúde
pública na cidade a nossa melhor
academia nossa academia mais acessível
mas chegou a hora de voltar para o
brasil não soubesse que encontrar aqui
mas antónio na cabeça a gente começou um
grupo a cidade ativa uma organização
social
alguns colegas a rafaela que também se
manifestará depois
e daí a gente tem uma atividade que
chama safáris urbanos
a gente vai para as calçadas desvendar
esse território misterioso e complexo
das calçadas né e bom para ficar óbvio
que a infraestrutura aqui de mobilidade
a fé é muito mais precária do que eu
tinha visto lá fora mas além disso outra
coisa me surpreendeu também ao contrário
de outros países
aqui as pessoas caminham mais onde a
infraestrutura é pior a gente pega dados
por exemplo de são paulo as pessoas que
mais caminha no dia a dia tanto nas
periferias
elas são pessoas de baixa renda pessoas
que na verdade não têm acesso ao
transporte
elas não têm o recurso para pagar uma
passagem de ônibus duas vezes a linha
não passa perto de casa você não tem
outra escolha
o caminhar nas cidades brasileiras é a
falta de opção
isso chamou muita a nossa atenção e
apesar de isso tudo apesar da péssima
qualidade da infraestrutura
a gente olha para os deslocamentos
feitos no brasil todos os dias mais de
um terço são feitos exclusivamente a pé
nem parece né gente olha pra a
infraestrutura como assim alguém usa
isso todos os dias para se deslocar até
uma forma de transporte
não sei se você sabe não é considerada
uma chance ótima maneira de você colocar
pessoas e coisas no território
agora a gente pega se um terço se soma
com as pessoas que pegam o transporte
público
meus amigos e ativistas falam que a pé e
busão é que nem arroz com feijão é tão
sempre juntos
você tem que ir andando até o ponto de
ônibus ou sair do metrô para sua casa em
suma todo esse pessoal a gente tem mais
de dois terços de todas as viagens sendo
feitas a pé no brasil
agora a gente vai ser criterioso mesmo
além desses dois tentos
eu acredito que todos nós somos
pedestres todos vocês aí em algum
momento do dia né porque enfim que assim
tive a alima esquina perguntar se
andando no estacionamento do shopping
carregando bicicleta que a gente deixou
ali parada na frente da farmácia todos
nós somos pedestres independente das
nossas habilidades também quer deixar
isso claro quando falo pdf to falando de
todo mundo que usa energia do próprio
corpo para se locomover
então quando a gente fala das cidades
mais caminhar weiss
a gente tá falando de inclusão porque
quando falo de cidades caminhada do
fundo de construção das mais acessíveis
mais seguras para permitir que a mulher
possa andar com tranqüilidade a mulher à
pessoa com deficiência
o idoso à criança estou garantindo
acesso à cidade a todas essas pessoas
quando falo de idade e caminhadas tudo
bem que a gente entendeu que a cidade
caminhar weiss precisa dessa
infraestrutura mas a gente construir
mais calçadas e faixas de pedestre
será que as pessoas vão andar mais em
alguns lugares eu acho que sim
eu acho que alguns lugares também a
gente vai qualificar o caminho daquelas
pessoas que têm que fazer
isso né mas eu acho que a gente ainda
tem um problema muito grave
na estrutural mesmo da nossa cidade diz
que as coisas estão muito longe uma das
outras
nossa cidade estão muito espalhadas em
campinas
é muito difícil você escolher andar é
por seu trabalho no cinema fazer compra
desses destinos estão muito longe uns
dos outros
falar de cidades mas caminhava weiss é
falar de cidades um pouco mais compactas
muitas pessoas estão mais próximos
dessas atividades nosso dia a dia estão
mais próximas e engraçado então aqui
numa cidade de caminhada além de
caminhar é a forma mais eficiente
a meu ver a gente se deslocar pela
cidade a gente não usa energia nem o
combustível além daquele nossas próprias
calorias não emite nenhum poluente
nenhum gás de efeito estufa
a gente não tem que pagar nada além da
caminhada forma mais eficiente
ela também gera uma cidade muito mais
eficiente porque tem uma cidade mais
concentrada no território menor
todas as outras infra estruturas
funcionam melhor também o transporte
ontem que ali longe para buscar as
pessoas na água e esgoto tudo funciona
melhor e de forma mais eficiente na
cidade caminhava velho perguntou mas eu
queria saber que quem anda de carro no
dia a dia
muita gente né porque porque é mais
rápido mais fácil mais confortável
às vezes vai pegar o ônibus nem sabe que
horas a pagar passar ônibus que tony é
só passar eu trabalho pra cidade mas
caminhava eis porque eu quero que a
gente tem escolhas
eu não acho justo a gente tem que
escolher o carro
eu quero que essas outras escolhas o
caminhar a bicicleta o transporte
público sejam igualmente agradáveis
confiáveis seguras a gente poder se
deslocar de outra maneira eu acho que a
gente tem que se culpar a que hoje é
feita essa escolha pode fazer essa
escolha todos os dias eu acho que a
gente tem que se culpar como sociedade
porque o fato é agente privilegiou o
carro
nos nossos projetos e nas nossas
políticas públicas
é só parar e olhar para a rua com as
faltas não está tão bom quanto eu
gostaria mas o asfalto recebe o
investimento público é mantido nessas
prefeituras a calçada seja viram que
acontece na maioria dos casos quem tem
que manter a calçada é o proprietário do
imóvel porque isso porque o semáforo
fica muito mais tempo aberto do carro
que a pessoa tem que cruzar a pé já
sabem qual é a metodologia pra definir
se esse time já fui lá contar com as
pessoas cruzam a rua quando os carros
passam mais tempo nas velocidades
máximas
estamos permitindo também nos perímetros
urbanos são bons para o carro que o
carro é rápido não se chegava em casa
mas pra quem tá caminhando do lado
aquela velocidade representam risco
eu acho que esse modelo tem um limite na
nossa cidade tem um limite o espaço é
limitado a gente conseguir mais faixas
mais pontes mas e adultos da cidade
caminhar weiss falar então de inverter
essas prioridades de abrir espaço para o
pedestre o ciclista eo transporte
público para que isso seja uma opção
também é uma opção confiável então
também luta para a cidade mais
caminhadas para que a gente seja um
pouco menos dependente do carro no nosso
dia a dia que ele seja menos essencial
agora outra coisa que eu descobrir nessa
minha caminhada foi que só compartilha
da idéia e olhar para o lado e vi muita
gente e também acreditava em si das
caminhadas e cada um com a sua motivação
em 5 sobre se ele tinha outras e foi
muito legal essas pessoas essas
organizações que estão lutando pelo tema
aqui no brasil e pensando nisso nós da
cidade ativa dos nossos colegas da
corrida amiga
começamos o projeto como anda o comanda
hoje é um ponto de encontro uma
plataforma virtual que permite conectar
essas organizações além de ajudar a
fortalecer o tema
hora da nossa bolha conta fazendo aqui
hoje conversando um pouco com vocês
além de ajudar a articular essa rede
o como anda tem como papel também trazer
subsídios na insumo dados para
fortalecer esses grupos
dentre as várias coisas que a gente tem
ali um site é ter um formulário que
qualquer organização ou pessoa
interessada pode preencher quando a
organização está falando de instituições
de ensino órgãos de prefeituras para seu
escritório de arquitetura e engenharia
ongs e coletivos porque é um trabalho de
alguma forma como mobilidade até então
esses grupos podem preencher o
formulário e os dados de celular e falou
um pouco sobre a forma de atuar como a
gente fala da minha vida já tem no nosso
dia a dia
esses dados à mão todos uma um gráfico
interativo
vocês visitarem o site hoje pois o
colégio vocês vão ver alguns filtros
vocês conseguem encontrar as
organizações usando o mapa os sistemas
ilegal disso essa ferramenta é muito
poderosa para mim
permite se encontra essa troca de idéias
entre os grupos que lutam por cidades
mais caminhadas com ela esse é um caso
de sucesso nossa esses dois grupos
trabalham de uma forma muito parecida
eles não se conheciam antes do como anda
o que eles compartilham né compartilham
uma ideia que é roxa as crianças devem
usar mais as ruas os espaços públicos
eles compartilham também uma forma de
fazer que é ajudar essas crianças a irem
a pé para a escola e vai ficar
compartilho também das ideal na cidade
mas caminhava
mas acho que principalmente eles também
compartilham um desejo de fazer as
coisas de uma maneira diferente
faz todo dia a gente pode fazer de uma
maneira diferente
eu quero muito que minha filha possa ir
até a escola diferente de mim eu quero
muito aqui mas não posso parar de
brincar depois pela universidade
e trabalhar a pé eu luto por isso todos
os dias porque uma cidade de caminhar
viveu
ela vai continuar tendo essa liberdade
mais direito de ir e vir
ela está conquistando agora isso morre
que mal e vocês obrigada
[Aplausos]